welcome back to the gadget lab I am
Michael colori I'm Nathan only about his
Giles on this week's show we're going to
take a look at a new phone from HTC and
then Robbie Baldwin is going to come on
and we're going to talk about some
inexpensive gadgets to spend your tax
refund on and we're going to look at a
new bluetooth portable speaker also we
have the ipad 3 case from last week that
we're going to give away from pen and
quill and we will be announcing the
winners at the end of the show but first
the HTC one s so this is a brand new
smart phone from HTC available
exclusively on t-mobile and their
billing it as the flagship phone for
tmobile not the flagship phone for HTC
but for tmobile for t-mobile so it runs
ICS it's the only Ice Cream Sandwich
phone on t-mobile is irvin right now is
the only Ice Cream Sandwich phone on
t-mobile but HTC has basically rebooted
their entire smartphone lineup and
they're putting out a series of phones
called the 1 series the actual top dog
of the 1 series is going to AT&T it's
called the 1x this is the 1s so what's
the difference is between the x and the
S well actually on the inside for the
u.s. versions there about the same
they're both running a 1.5 gigahertz
dual-core processor have about the same
specs actually the same 8-megapixel
camera a really good camera really good
camera software and they're both running
ice cream sandwich with this sense for
user interface which is the first
version of sense that I just honestly
did not hate genuine yeah it was like
sense of all the rappers that I've
different manufacturers put on their
phones i think sense is the most
palatable yeah this one's up not bad
it's actually kind of nice because it's
not very much in the way it's very 2d
feeling the big clock is still there but
it doesn't really feel like it's slowing
down android like a lot of past versions
of sense and other you know skins /
android felt like but for every aspect
of this phone the one asked that i liked
i found something i didn't like so sense
is great the operating system is not bad
but the screen is
what's called a qhd screen and honestly
the resolution is low if you're going to
build this to me as a flagship phone
this year would have been great last
year but we're on a 720p at least now
and that just doesn't keep up it has a
really nice super thin and light you
know body here nice aluminum materials
kind of interesting gradient but the
camera sticks out I feel like it would
get scratched really easily yeah and
yeah there's still like little gaps
between different parts of the body here
which is kind of something you see on
HTC phones a lot so I feel like for
everything that I liked about it there
was also something I didn't like and
just didn't live up to that flagship
standard that I wanted it to yeah
because the flagship phone really has to
compete with the likes of an iphone or a
Galaxy Nexus from Samsung yeah something
with a really nice sharp screen and
superfast good performance yeah if
you're gonna if you're gonna ask me for
200 bucks and I'm gonna have to live
with this for the next two years of my
life I want it to be something I'm going
to love using every single day and when
your screen is subpar that's the first
thing that this is what you're gonna be
looking at touching every single day so
it's green technology not only is
already better than what's in this phone
but is going to continue to improve the
next year so exactly it's a good place
to if you want a future proof your
device you choose a screen that's better
than no doubt no doubt and so in our
review we gave it a six and just didn't
really live up to what you wanted it to
which technically is still a
recommendation so if you're yeah if you
are a tmobile diehard customer and
you're looking for a new phone I mean
you could definitely spend your two
hundred dollars on something worse yeah
444 t-mobile this is probably the best
phone on t-mobile right now other than
maybe the samsung galaxy s2 but if you
have the option of looking at different
phones I would definitely check out the
Galaxy Nexus you know maybe some stuff
from Motorola over at Verizon there's
lots of different options out there and
the One X which is coming to AT&T and
has a much better screen alright so
that's the latest with the HTC phones
Thank You Nathan thank you and let's
bring out Robbie so we can talk about
how cheap you are all right Robbie's
here hi Robbie you're a cheap bastard
I am a cheap bastard and during tax time
I become even more of a cheap bastard
faster because I might end up paying
taxes and if you ended up paying taxes
you're probably not going to run out and
buy a brand new you know
eight-hundred-dollar iPad instead Here I
get something cheap and what I did is I
found some cheap gadgets that people can
get right now so I found this watch it's
the four dollars on amazon.com and it's
actually pretty cool like it's it's
shiny you can see yourself so you want
to buy a mirror and you push this button
and a lights up like old-school weed
that's pretty sweet yeah that's a four
dollar one more dollar watch i also find
found a ten-dollar mp3 player looks
suspiciously like an iPod shuffle yes
what's it called the Eclipse it's
Eclipse mp3 player oh and it clips onto
you put it's the clips get it yeah get
it I see what you did there so this was
ten dollars for two gigabytes there's a
little bit of noise in the sound but ten
bucks ten boxes ten boxes and then i
also got that a burner phone so if you
watch the wire you know burner phones
youjizz sure the page you go phone this
was a twenty bucks and you can top this
off stringer bells yes Marlo Stanfield
it's not you know it's it doesn't it has
mobile web but don't bother is it of a
camera so you can take pictures of it
will not have a camera but it says you
can send pictures okay so you just okay
I guess you could download pictures and
send those or somebody send you a
picture and then you turn out some that
to somebody else and then the worst
thing i found was this digital camera
that's a key chain that has spider-man
on it and you would think spider-man
wouldn't allow his good name to be put
on such a horrible product but it was so
what'swhat's shitty about it well first
of all the viewfinder is worthless like
if I put it up here everything's blurry
it's just like a little plastic lens it
would only take 20 pictures and it only
works with windows XP and 2000 I
couldn't get to work on windows 7 really
yeah what about vista No so it did you
try linux no I tried the mac i tried
everything i couldnt get to show up so
wow so how much was that this was ten
dollars no but i suspect all the money
probably went to licensing the the
superman the
I'm answered that the spider-man
likeness on the front and they didn't do
a very good job because they cut into
his face which is something you don't
want to do when you're trying to yeah
they don't care they got their dollars
in essence they got my money from me so
so in addition to the cheap gadgets he
also did a gallery of gadgets for people
who have so much money that they can
afford accounts to not have to pay any
taxes right yes yeah the ultra-rich so
we had a really awesome guitar Tamina
titanium we had a toilet which is my
favorite product on the list and the
Kohler Numi it's six thousand dollars
and it warms your bum and it has forced
air that warms your feet yeah so you
want a route from yeah I keep your feet
warm in the morning that's pretty
awesome when you walk up the toilet
automatically opens and lights and has
speakers in it so you talk to you and
agree to now you can play music it'll
play has like it has music that's
already pre-installed on the toilet but
you can also plug like your iphone or
ipod vogner flight of the Valkyries yes
there is a ride of the Valkyries I know
we give comments but to be yeah don't
throw dog dr. Idon't that'd be awesome
but just play that off I what's going on
in there you don't want to know so send
me your six thousand dollars does it
tweet it doesn't tweet but does have a
touchscreen interface which is weird it
yeah touchscreen interface they figure
you know you're bringing your phone into
the bathroom with you anyway filthy
filthy filthy well you can you can look
at and read both of Robbie's galleries
both for the cheap gadgets and the
ridiculously expensive gadgets on the
gadget lab okay last week on the podcast
we gave away or give the opportunity to
give away give away two cases from this
company pad and quill they are a
mom-and-pop organization in the Midwest
and make these handsome leather and wood
cases for the ipad 3 and we had a trivia
question it was what is the arthur c
clarke novel that shares its name with
the pink floyd's or in other words the
arthur c clarke novel childhoods end
which Pink Floyd used as a song title on
the album obscured by clouds written by
Dave Gilmour
the winners are Michael Smith otherwise
known as biker Mike on Twitter and
Joshua gotcher hope I'm pronouncing
those correctly we will get in touch
with you two lucky winners and we will
send you your ipad cases shortly and if
we don't there's nothing you can do
about it so don't complain the last
thing we have is this speaker from sound
freak look at this that's a you know
when I before when I find cheap don't
buy cheap tools by the way I made sure
not to put cheap tools on the list
because cheap tools break and I've
bloodied all of these knuckles with
cheap tools but I would buy cheap tools
and sometimes may become in cases like
this come on case well this this is this
is not a cheap tool however it is
extraordinarily inexpensive for the
product category this is a Bluetooth
wireless speaker so the idea is you
charge it up and then you take it out
with you has battery inside the last 48
hours supposedly I tested it I got about
six and a half seven hours out of it but
it's a speaker that has a couple of
drivers in it a couple of speakers in
the front so it's stereo and they're
nice and wide so you get a good stereo
image the back pops out and it leans and
it kicks back like that and projects
sound into the room it's kind of a nice
design it's it's bigger than the leader
of the category which is the jam box
which is a little bit around half as
small as this but the jam box is 200
bucks and it's loud but it's not quite
loud enough this the sound freak sound
kick which I can't believe I just forgot
to mention until right now but anyway
the sound freak sound kick is only a
hundred dollars so it's half the price
of a jam box and it's Bluetooth just
like the the gin boxes so it works
waived your iphone or ipad your computer
in and it's it's got around the same
battery life and it sounds better it's
louder it's clearer and the highs and
the lows so it's really nice by 400
bucks do you test it with listening to
rush no I just put it on shuffle just so
I had a solid mix of everything some fog
nirsa Beethoven you know the big ones a
lot of pain Floyd but so there's a
little bit of context around this
category too because we
there is a rumor or a couple of rumors
floating around that the job of people
who make the Jambox are going to be
releasing a new version of it probably
something bigger around the same size as
the sound kick that is going to cost
about three times the money as the sound
kick so if I would recommend you go out
and get one of these right now if you
need a good wireless speaker because
it's really great as a wireless speaker
I've been up in more than impressed with
it for the week or so spent with it but
if you love your jam box you may want to
wait and see what jawbone is going to be
coming out with we expect within the
next few months to hear here's something
from them so for now there's no real
news on on them on the better jam box so
the category remains a race between the
two hundred dollar device in the
100-dollar device cheaper and I should
mention it folds up slips into a
backpack or you can stack it on top of
your beautiful leather ipad 3 case and
take it with you to the park yay anyway
that's all we have for this week we'll
come back next week we'll probably have
some more phones more tablets more
speakers some more cheap news from
Robbie until then you can check out all
of our latest reviews of wired com /
reviews and you can visit the gadget lab
section at wired.com / gadget lab